all right iron law podcast Lords the
gaming dotnet Lord sovereign we are here
who is its fine lady of the realm today
okay right and what is your role
actually with bleeding edge awesome
awesome
so for those who've been living under a
rock who watch the Xbox briefing
yesterday we saw this what can you
explain is the premise of leading-edge
basically games and I just wanted to
combine those two passions right the
thing I love to make the thing I love to
play let's put them together where is
this game it doesn't exist exactly
exactly so any inspirations anything's
all behind it because I know we've been
getting some pop power stone bomb from
the beginning I just thought like Power
Stone like so once I saw that I was I
was sold that's all I needed to see and
for me like cuz I'm not big on
necessarily the the gun commenter would
not but melee combat I'm all the way in
besides Power Stone also I kind of got
like a mad world that was something that
really attracted me to the game so any
other influences that you had I mean I
played every movie ever since like the
original dota in the Warcraft 3 engines
Warcraft 3 is one of my favorite games
[Music]
classic it's a marina stuff in there
some PvP class based shooters wow she's
throwing out classic heavy hitters right
aviators it's like team-based and it's
multiplayer I'm down basically
so for people who don't know like as far
as the development I know listen people
somewhere coming from that the
hell-blade team and things of that
nature this was a little bit of change
of pace so how long would you guys been
in development as far as working on this
specific title most of the people that
are here just to be clear this is
something you guys have been working on
nothing was halted to stop always been
[Music]
did you get any resistance from this
idea again okay the thing is once I saw
the combat I said no that's ninja
theories alley so it's just a matter of
getting the concept somebody to buy into
the concept so you didn't get much
resistance at all it's absolutely fun
because we're talking to the legend
right here so I'm just I'm so glad you
said that because there was a lot of
misconception on the interwebs about
design choices and so forth so just to
hear you say that is actually really
refreshing so we're looking at you said
a public trial what are we looking at as
far as getting this in our hands at home
well we're gonna be opening the public
tech out starting on June 27 so it's by
kind of invitation so you sign up on our
website and then yeah we'll start
letting people in a bit at a time expand
it and
just super pumped to see what the
players think and their feedbacks not
tweaking the game together make it cool
awesome like all the combat stuff like
is there any story stuff behind it and
you have like an overarching story about
the characters yeah like there's kind of
a backstory to the world like all these
guys are kind of on the extremes on the
fringes of society what people are
willing to do with their bodies and it's
kind of that like the thing that makes
them different to everyone else that
brings them together and they join
together as part of like kind of a tech
Club hacking like augmenting each other
and then they sort of turned into a bit
of a Fight Club because they're like
well we've done all these augments now
we need to test it right and that's what
bleeding edge is it's like a club of
guys we've come together through their
shared love of kind of extreme body
hacking I love this is now like what
happens at the break they're all buddies
right and that's why you know the end of
the trailer you see like a selfie shot
they all mates at the end they all gone
home together having a beer in the
basement and each each each fight has
got their own reason for being there and
you can read about that online on our
website there's BIOS in the game so yeah
plenty to it currently right now as far
as character account and as far as stage
is what are we looking at we got 10
fighters in the game right now with 3
maps and each map can support two game
modes awesome any other questions so get
ready to get in the lords hatches to
meet with the legend here the discuss
bleeding edge one of them two theories
new IPs looks fantastic Xbox exclusive
and we're gonna get that public trial an
absolute pleasure to have you around
she's a busy woman thank you so much
gaming net signing out